this week is going to be a very exciting
week because this week
i am exclusively only using the oneplus
9 pro phone
and this is going to be so exciting
because i've done so many phone reviews
before
but never have i just exclusively used
an android device for an
entire week i have been using this phone
since the day that it came out a huge
thank you to oneplus for sponsoring this
video and giving me this really fun
idea for a video it's so funny seeing
you guys react to my tweets on twitter
when you saw
audible gasp uh sent from an android
i've done phone reviews before but this
is gonna be very
very different i also asked you guys on
twitter for some suggestions on things
that i should know
going into this you guys gave me some
advice you gave me some cool apps to
test out and one of the things that my
biggest concern was is how am i going to
be transferring my photos
to my phone as seamlessly as i was
before i think the best advice that i'd
received is using google photos and then
also just
using the telegram app because with that
i'm able to send myself photos and
they'll be high quality and i can just
download them directly from there
with that little piece of information i
am set to go
thing that i have really loved a lot
about this phone so far is the
hasselblad camera system
these are so incredible the fact that
hasselblad and oneplus have kind of
co-developed
not only these lenses but the technology
inside of the phone
there's a really cool pro mode feature
that we're going to be testing out later
this week
you guys might know tyler he edits a lot
of these videos and he's
actually shooting this right now we're
gonna be going out and doing kind of
like a little photo shoot so i'm excited
to see his take on this
as a pro photographer himself and
testing out the pro mode
inside of this phone well for now i'm
gonna start this video off
by filming my first video for this video
on the phone
i don't want to shoot it in 8k but the
fact that i can shoot an 8k
is pretty exciting and we are off to the
races look at me
racing day one with the oneplus 9 pro
[Music]
so i think i'm gonna do is post this
picture on instagram
and see if people can guess which camera
i took it with
since this is day one everyone's kind of
speculating they're like
which phone is she using for the week
this is it my friends
let's see who can guess we've been
causing quite a stir on twitter
because my first tweet from this morning
was
i forget what it was the important fact
was it was sent from an android device
and
people are going crazy they just can't
believe it they can't believe it's true
rich never thought he'd see the day the
day's here rich
it's here the guesses
are rolling in we've already got some
correct ones one plus nine pro
there we go there we go another one plus
nine pro one plus that's a lot of
responses
i don't ever ask questions very often
should i share a response to them should
i
share it back like yeah you're right
dude not yet
they can't know yet we'll wait until
tomorrow i should probably go make a
tick tock now
we should always be making tick tocks
maybe i'll just go watch tick tock
girl don't do it at the grocery
bag
right now i'm shooting in 8k it's really
wild to think that cell phones now
are capable of shooting in this high
quality of
video i'm excited i'm gonna shoot a
feature film maybe
working on the script right now as we
speak
so now here's 8k zoomed out a little bit
is this is it a little wider of an angle
here's my feature film i've started it
i'm going to start shooting it here
this is where it will start this is
probably where it'll end
it's very short short feature
we're making a a dog cake it's just a
very long time ago
break approximately for 25 to 30 minutes
or until a toothpick
inserted into the center comes out i
think
another fun day with oneplus 9 pro i'm
off on a hike right now it is
so beautiful today we're actually
filming all day so i thought i would try
to get out early
and enjoy some nature take some photos
just get outside before i'm stuck inside
all day
[Music]
stabilization on this it's really nice i
love having like the wide angle lens
looks really good i also hear a beehive
somewhere
just gonna try to find a foot probably
not something i should be doing
[Music]
we're doing photo testing now it's a
pretty windy day
this hasselblad camera system is amazing
let's take my first selfie with this
beautiful hair
[Music]
because it's not portrait mode but look
at the wow
that's actually incredible
color me impressed let's get those
filters on
[Music]
hey
wow super macro super macro look at this
piece of fuzz
look at that go get some pictures of
like some coffee
or do you want pictures of coffee or is
that cause you want coffee you want
coffee do you want coffee where can we
go to get coffee
do you think i need a coffee i don't
know it's hard to say we can get a
coffee
i like coffee okay
we've got coffee written music happening
but this is my favorite coffee shop this
is good people coffee i gotta try latte
i'm happy
[Music]
so i thought i'd get outside get some
fresh air and try a new hike
this is supposed to have turtles there's
supposed to be turtles here and
don't see any yet wow
look at your body and face it's cool
hey can i get rabies from this i don't
feel like i'm a threat
but do you feel like
do you have an itch that i can assist
you with
hey maddie are you a good boy another
day with the oneplus 9 pro
we are going for a walk right now it's
so nice outside i sometimes take for
granted the los angeles weather because
it's like every day is
usually a nice day is every day
a nice hair day oh that's
up for debate
[Music]
it has been a really fun week with the
oneplus 9 pro
and honestly the transition was
incredibly easy i mean basically all i
had to do
was swap my sim and really the only
difference was for recipients of my
messages because they were now turned
into text messages
but a lot of my friends actually use
telegram or whatsapp
so i did end up using a lot of those
apps to continue conversations so that
i'd be able to have those on my computer
and on my phone and all the
conversations were very seamless i
actually used telegram a lot for photo
transfers because i would be on my
computer and then i would just
telegram myself and i could download
those full hi-res videos and photos
to be able to post on twitter or on
instagram using google photos i was able
to sync all of the content from my
computer
to my phone so everything was also very
consistent there
the thing that i really am just so
in love with is this display the oneplus
9 pro has this new fluid display 2.0
and this is an all-new generation of
advanced mobile display that integrates
ltpo technology
that allows you to have lightning fast
touch response for gaming and they're
calling this hyper touch so with hyper
touch it's allowing you to get six times
faster syncing in gaming so just imagine
if you're playing a first person shooter
like pubg
you're gonna have a significant
advantage over other people who do not
have this hyper touch
display typical syncing speeds between
the processor and display is 60 or 120
hertz but with hyper touch they've been
able to increase it to 360 hertz
that is a pretty significant increase in
response time and if you've ever played
any type of first person shooter video
games you will know that that is one of
the most important things
so this is the morning mist color and
this one is probably my favorite
but i was very very surprised because
oneplus sent me the pine green to check
out so i had no idea they were sending
this one
and when i saw the color was like oh
look at this
this is such a pretty color it's
actually kind of like a
more of a teal with like a little hint
of blue
kind of i also like that it has kind of
a matte finish whereas this one is super
reflective
i do love the morning mist color
but i feel like this mat looks really
good on camera too
so they also have the stellar black
version and the specs on this device
you can choose between 8 or 12 gigs of
ram 128 or 256 gigs of storage
it has a 4 500 milliamp hour battery and
this display is a 6.7
inch 120 hertz display i know i've been
talking so much about that
if you've never experienced 120hz
display before it is so
seamless and quick and everything is
just so smooth
so this ltpo technology is able to cut
the oneplus 9 pros display power
consumption by up to 50
thanks to their smart 120hz feature
which will automatically match the
refresh rate to the current user
scenario so it can go as low as one
hertz if you're just viewing photos
or reading to 24 hertz if you're
watching movies and then even as high as
120 hertz when you're scrolling so with
this this is definitely saving you
battery life
speaking of battery life the other thing
that i was very impressed with is how
fast i could charge
this phone using warp charge 65t you can
go from one to 100 in just 29 minutes
and this was actually quite helpful
because i had actually forgot to charge
this one day
and as i was heading out the door i was
like no so i gave myself an extra 15
minutes
and that basically gave me enough charge
to last the rest of the day
the oneplus 9 pro is able to achieve
these speeds because it's using a custom
4500 milliamp battery with an improved
dual cell design to reduce internal
resistance and heating while charging
so this gives the oneplus 9 pro the
ability to charge at higher outputs for
an extended period of time to fill up
the battery faster there's also warp
charge 50 wireless which is
also very impressive i also really love
the way that this charger looks
so not only will it charge my phone one
to 100
in about 43 minutes but it also looks
really great
so if you guys know me or if you've
watched any of my videos before you know
that smartphone cameras are
my absolute favorite thing to test so
when oneplus
announced this collaboration with
hasselblad i mean
all of us camera nerds were super
excited about this the new hasselblad
pro mode is bringing hasselblad level
sensor calibration to a smartphone for
the first time we're getting that iconic
hasselblad color performance and
accuracy
right here in the palm of our hands so i
took a bunch of photos and videos
obviously testing this out but i really
was quite surprised even with the depth
mode it was also
able to take some incredible portraits
of my dog something else that tyler who
helps edit and shoot my videos
we went out and took some photos and we
were so impressed with the way that you
were able
to manually adjust the focus we got a
couple really great shots demoing that
too
also can we talk about macro mode i'm
not a big fan of ants
but let me tell you what i'm pretty
fascinated by the fact that i was able
to capture them
this up close and personal using the
macro lens on the oneplus 9 pro so as
far as video you guys can actually shoot
8k
and i love being able to also
simultaneously take photos
while i'm capturing 8k or 4k footage i
made it
to the halfway point and i thought i
would test out shooting at 8k
so here's some incredible ak footage on
the oneplus 9 pro
something else that's really amazing is
you're able to take 12-bit raw photos
and some people may not be familiar with
what an actual raw image is
this is giving you so much more data to
be able to work with like adjusting the
highlights or the low lights
so if you're just shooting a regular
jpeg image this is something that you
would not be able to do in post
something else that i've loved about
this phone is how quick the in-screen
fingerprint reader was
unfortunately we still are in a time
where masks are a thing just being able
to pull my phone out of my pocket and
just touch
the screen is honestly something that
i've really
really missed and that is such a simple
small feature that i feel like is very
common in a lot of phones
i really loved it everything has been
running very smooth
i've gamed i've created content i have
done all of my social media
over the past week basically on this
device i've watched
an absurd amount of tick-tock not proud
of it but
hey it's what i like to do and spend my
time doing i've enjoyed playing games
i tested out the pub g mobile which is
one of the games that takes advantage of
the hyper touch feature
and not all games are currently
supporting that but the ones that do you
better believe that having hyper touch
is gonna give you a very
large competitive advantage i mean
honestly i've not played pub g mobile in
a very long time
and my performance was astounding you
would think that i was a professional
maybe i am a professional
who knows the 5g connectivity was
incredibly fast i have a t-mobile sim
card in here
and everywhere i went i feel like i was
pretty well covered overall i had a
really great experience and i had such a
fun week kind of getting to test this
out and sort of
see this phone in a whole new light this
is kind of my favorite part of the hike
it's leading you up towards the midway
point of like overlook but i love this
little trail it just looks so cool
and such a perfect little walk up and
then you're greeted with hey guess what
you're almost done with this hey
hello um do you remember that one place
that we used to go
to eat at on montana it closed a long
time ago
hmm okay well that's unfortunate
yeah like three years ago four years ago
very long time ago where have i been
i don't know it's weird because i was
just looking for it and i did find a
nice sweater
each piece is thirty dollars
there each piece is thirty dollars that
is actually a deal
you might want put your touch that
i know thank you so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video i had
such a fun week testing out the oneplus
9 pro thank you again to oneplus for
sponsoring this video this was such a
fun video to put together and i hope
that you guys enjoyed it